[Music]
what's up Wolfgang so a couple of days
ago we got some more updates on Wonder
Woman - and again it's not officially
titled Wonder Woman - but since we don't
have a title yet that's what we're gonna
refer to it as so it seems like filming
has begun which matches pretty well with
what director patty Jenkins said a few
weeks ago when she was asked when they
were going to start filming and she
replied shockingly soon
and this actually lines up with the
previous rumor that said production on
Wonder Woman too would begin in early
June before we get started just a
reminder about our speaker system
giveaway there is only three days left
for you to enter all you need to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel leave a
like and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero and that could be
from DC Marvel or anything so a couple
days ago gal gadot was spotted in trina
mall in alexandria virginia which is
where it's been reported that Wonder
Woman - will be filming some scenes but
it appears that she wasn't alone it is
also been reported that some people saw
Chris Pine entering the mall as well
this has been reported by a few people
and the key word here is reported this
is not anything released from the DC EU
or the director or Wonder Woman - in any
way but there has been multiple
reporting's and in fact one person even
attempted to take a video of a person
getting out of a car who they say it was
Chris Pine it's hard to see cuz it's
taken from very far away and there's a
tree kind of in the way but we'll show
you the video
so this is going to be very interesting
if it is in fact Chris Pine because
Chris Pines character Steve Trevor died
in Wonder Woman or maybe that's just
what we were meant to think after the
first Wonder Woman I've often thought
Steve Trevor is a pilot and there's got
to be a parachute somewhere on that
plane that he took so it would seem to
me that his pilot instincts would sink
in at some point in time and he would
look for a parachute and he could just
jump off but who knows what we do know
is that cheetah will be the main villain
and Wonder Woman too and Steve Trevor is
very much alive in that series and not
to mention that Wonder Woman too will be
taking place in the 1980s and Steve
Trevor died in the 1940s so if he is
spotted on set and this is legitimate
then it seems like his character Steve
Trevor will be in Wonder Woman too now
of course some people are saying that it
could just very well be some flashbacks
from Wonder Woman one but in Wonder
Woman they were never in a mall in
Alexandria Virginia I mean they could
always do a flashback to a scene that
actually wasn't in Wonder Woman or you
know it was kind of like a scene that we
never saw it's just personal between her
and Steve Trevor but again a mall in
Alexandria Virginia I don't know what
they could possibly use there or explain
how they were there in the first Wonder
Woman but everybody really loved Chris
Pine playing Steve Trevor so it would
make sense that they would want to bring
him back in some way and again in the
storyline with cheetah he's alive the
whole time so it would make sense for
them to have him in this film as well so
for the update on Wonder Woman - it
seems like they have started filming and
if they haven't it seems like they're
going to start very very soon and it
seems like Chris Pine might be in the
next Wonder Woman movie hit me with your
thoughts below do you think that this is
Chris Pine do you think he's gonna be in
the next Wonder Woman movie or do you
think this is just some rumor and this
is just some random guy and a white
t-shirt and let me know what you're most
excited about for a Wonder Woman - if
you enjoyed this video give it a thumbs
up and be sure
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Wonderwoman to DC and everything
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]